[Music]
[Music]
I get that okay welcome everybody my
name is Doug Bradburn
I'm the founding director of the Fred
Davey Smith National Library for the
Study of George Washington here at
beautiful Mount Vernon and delighted to
welcome you all again for a wonderful
evening of conversation and history and
I'd also like to welcome the c-span
audience out there who's recording us
this evening it's great to have you back
in the library you know these four word
evening book talks are special for a
variety of reasons because we get to
bring exciting new historians to the
Iger community here but also because
it's sponsored by a Ford which has been
a great donor to Mount Vernon for many
many years as you all know Mount Vernon
ladies Association does not take any
government money it's a completely
private institution based on
philanthropy and based on people coming
to the estate and so we depend on groups
like the Ford family and the Ford Motor
Company who've supported Mount Vernon
since Henry Ford gave the first fire
engine to Mount Vernon to keep the
mansion-house from burning to the ground
so as some of you know it's an ongoing
challenge in fact you're welcome to
donate to our fire suppression efforts
right now I'd like to welcome you all
out here and before we begin the main
event I also want to mention some
upcoming library programs of which we
still have some tickets available great
our annual Martha Washington lecture
featuring flora Frazer in Zahra and ash
Anglin discussing 18th century women as
consumers on both sides of the Atlantic
that's going to be a fantastic
conversation led by our own Susan Shore
who's the senior curator here at Mount
Vernon and we have the first of three
Michelle Smith lectures coming up
featuring George Goodwin discussing
Benjamin Franklin in London the British
life of America's founding father on
March 30th and that's when you
definitely want to try to sign up for I
met George in London at the Benjamin
Franklin house which is an extraordinary
little house-museum there and he has got
an extremely large personality and I
think that you all will particularly
enjoy him and his discovery of
Franklin's life in London alright but
let's get to the main event right away
we are exceptionally pleased to have
with us a dr. Erica Armstrong Dunbar
from the University of Delaware with us
tonight you might have seen her featured
in the New York Times recently and on
many NPR programs but this is where she
belongs talking about a very important
subject she received her MA and PhD from
Columbia University in 2011 she became
the inaugural director of the program in
african-american history at the Library
Company of Philadelphia they should have
called you the founding director I mean
that's the that's the the most as we say
around here her first book a fragile
freedom african-american women and
emancipation in the antebellum City
published by Yale extremely well regard
an important study of an under studied
topic up to that point and so the
perfect person to take on the challenge
to recover the story of own a judge
let's all give Erika a big round of
applause
[Applause]
Hey
good evening everyone happy Black
History Month here I am so first let me
make offer a few thank-yous of course to
doug Bradburn who invited me i really
think that there's no other place that i
should be giving this talk can you all
see me I'm vertically challenged and I'm
gonna turn this let's see see if this is
better better yes okay and I'd also like
to state thank Steve and Emily for
helping me with arrangements to to
arrive here it's been a very very busy
week this book just came out on Tuesday
of last week and so I'm Kanak adem ik
and as Doug said my first book was
published with wale Yale University
Press
and this book is more of a sort of
crossover trade book for a larger more
general audience and so it's a very
different experience one that's been
rewarding but different and I'm a little
tired so forgive me if my voice comes in
and out I've been talking more than
usual so tonight is such a pleasure to
be here to be really where the story of
onna judges life began right it's Mount
Vernon and what I'll do tonight is to
talk a little bit I'll read a little bit
too from the book and give you a little
context through some slides about oh
here we are I'm in stereo
yay and to give you a little context
about onna judges life and really sort
of what I wanted to do with this book
about 20 years ago I was doing some
research on my first book about
african-american women in the North and
I came across an advertisement
for a runaway an enslaved person who had
run from the president's house in
Philadelphia was May 1796 and I was you
know sort of caught up looking through
microfilm at old newspapers and but this
made me pause and I said wait who is
this person who ran away she was named
Oney judge in the advertisement I
thought wait a minute
I don't know this person and that was
troubling to me because this is my area
of expertise I'm supposed to know all of
this stuff and I had no idea who this
Oney judge was and there was something
that was very sort of compelling about
this advertisement never sort of escaped
me and I said you know I'm gonna come
back to this important story I'm going
to try and trace this woman I need
answers so I finished the first book and
Here I am many years later it was a
lengthy process in attempting to recover
the work of the life of ona judge this
is recovery work and for those of us who
do specifically African American
American history doing this kind of work
in archives where the evidence is slim
factual evidence often doesn't exist
because people of color women in
particular often remain outside of the
archives and so what I will say is that
there's absolutely no way I could have
written this book had I not written my
first book so that's my plug for
graduate students and people who are
really doing the work of academics I
needed a grounding in order to be able
to write this book about a woman who is
really just absolutely magnificent when
you read this book you'll be blown away
by her life now many folks here in this
room and of course at Mount Vernon
this is no new story we know about own a
judge and you are among a small group of
people will actually now I hope there
many more who know her that's the the
expectation I want her name to become
one of those sort of household names
like a Frederick Douglas like a Harriet
Tubman because she runs away decades
before they do right so the title I'll
give you a sort of quick story about the
title never caught this was actually one
of my my first choices for the title of
the book and I presented it to some
people at the publishers and hated it
and they said gives away the story Erika
I said yeah but so does 12 years of
slave
I mean honestly we understand right it
was 12 years it's gonna end at some
point with never caught this is really a
history of how a woman who was a
fugitive never found freedom she was
never free she simply was never caught
and I think it's a big distinction and
one that I wanted to make especially as
I was trying to kind of dismantle what
we think about slavery in the south and
the north at this moment where the
nation is new and I think that's one of
the other things I was really trying to
do with this book was to allow us to see
what the early days of this new country
looked like through the eyes of the
enslaved and ona's life gives us that
opportunity to look at early Virginia
New York Pennsylvania and New Hampshire
and we get to sort of follow her life
and look at how this nation is changing
how its grappling with the issue of
slavery all of these very kind of
central issues to this new nation and
this time we're doing it through a young
black woman who made the choice to run
away so as I said
I'll read a bit I will talk and we'll
look at a few slides and we'll walk
together on this journey of ona's life
spring rain drenched the streets of
Philadelphia in 1796 weather in the City
of Brotherly Love was often fickle at
this time of year vacillating between
extreme cold and oppressive heat but
rain was almost always appreciated in
the nation's capital
it erased the putrid smells of rotting
food animal waste and filth that
permeated the cobblestone roads of this
new nation it reminded philadelphians
that the long and punishing winter was
behind them spring rain cleanse the
streets and souls of philadelphians
it assured in optimism and hope and a
feeling of rebirth and in the midst of
the promises of spring own a judge a
young black enslaved woman received
devastating news she learned that she
would leave Philadelphia a city that had
become her home judge would travel back
to Virginia and prepare herself to be
bequeathed to her owners granddaughter
today I'll introduce one of the most
under studied fugitive slaves in America
at the age of 22
judge stole herself from the
Washington's
forcing the President to show a slave
catching hand as a fugitive
judge would test the president's will
and his reputation the most important
man in the nation heralded with winning
the American Revolution could not
reclaim this enslaved woman ona judge
did what very few others could do
she beat the president judge was never
caught now I normally show this next
slide you all don't need it because
we're here at Mount Vernon and it's
actually an older slide but this is when
I'm on the road and doing my dog and
pony show this is one of there are of
course earlier images but I always try
to give this image so that people have
an idea of what the mansion house where
she was for such a long period of her
life for good 16 years and so of course
you all were here so you don't need this
but today I will introduce what I'm
calling I'm calling her a new American
hero a slave girl raised at Mount Vernon
who once exposed to the ideas of freedom
was compelled to pursue it at any cost
this was a woman who found the courage
to defy the president the wit to find
allies to escape to out-negotiate to run
to survive her story at this point we
can tell is really the only existing
lengthy account of a fugitive once held
by the Washington's at least told from
her mouth to interviewers it perhaps the
only fugitive account from any slave in
eighteenth-century Virginia and judges
life exposes the sting of slavery the
drive of defiance she guarded what would
become sort of freedom for her every day
of her life
never regretting her decision to fight
for what she believed to be her right
and that was freedom
in 1789 we know that Washington was
elected first President of the United
States traveled to New York the nation's
first Capitol and he and Martha
Washington would take with them seven
slaves from Mount Vernon this is a
sketch of Federal Hall where where
President Washington would take the oath
of office in New York so he would take
eventually Martha would make her way up
to New York she was unhappy about the
move and she made that known to everyone
but she went and they took seven
enslaved people with them from Mount
Vernon and ona judge was one of them she
would be taken from her mother Betty and
her other siblings and I'm going to read
a bit from the book to give you an idea
of what that moment must have been like
the young ona judge was far from an
experienced traveler the teenager knew
only Mount Vernon and its surroundings
and had never traveled far from her
family and loved ones for judge the move
must have been similar to the dreaded
auction block although she was not to be
sold to a different owner she was forced
to leave her family for an unfamiliar
destination hundreds of miles away judge
would have no choice but to stifle the
terror that she felt and to go on about
the work of preparing to move folding
linens packing Martha Washington's
dresses and personal accessories and
helping with the grandchildren these
were all things that own a judge would
be involved in
they were the tasks at hand and it
wasn't her place to complain or question
judge had to remount remain strong and
steady if not for herself then for her
mistress
who appeared to be falling apart at the
scenes like Judge Martha Washington had
no choice about the move to New York her
life was at the direction of her husband
who was now the most powerful man in the
country mrs. Washington and ona judge
may have shared similar concerns but of
course only Martha Washington was
allowed to express discontent and sorrow
Martha Washington was unhappy and
everyone knew it
including her frightened slave the
president's nephew Robert Lewis would
also soon be made aware of it when he
arrived at the estate on May 14th things
were in disarray Lewis who served as
Washington's secretary between 1789 and
91 was chosen to escort his aunt and her
grandchildren to New York but was
surprised and a bit concerned when he
arrived to find a frenzied and hectic
scene Lewis wrote quote everything
appeared to be in confusion end quote
the manifestation of mrs. Washington's
conflicting feelings Robert Lewis
described the departure which finally
took place on May 16th 1789 as an
emotional moment for the slaves and the
first lady quote after an early dinner
and making all necessary arrangements in
which we were greatly [ __ ] it
brought us to 3 o'clock in the afternoon
when we left Mount V the servants of the
house and a number of the field Negroes
made their appearance to take to take
leave of their mistress numbers of these
poor wretches seemed greatly agitated
much affected my aunt equally so Betty
owned a judge's mother must have been
one of those agitated slaves not only
was she losing her 16 year old daughter
but she was also losing her son
who would serve as one of the
Washington's waiters Austin's wife
Charlotte and their children would have
joined in the morning Betty watched her
children leave Mount Vernon a reminder
of what little control slave mothers had
over the lives of their children if she
found any comfort in that day it would
have been that brother and sister were
traveling together
Austin was older and male and could look
out for his younger sister still Betty
knew that her relationship with her
children would never be the same the
Washington's would travel to New York
and would really their visit there was
relatively brief they would leave for
Philadelphia and November of 1790 when
the sight of the nation's capital
changed again ona would go with the
Washington's and she would be one of
nine enslaved people who traveled to
Philadelphia so we're going to go head
head south actually to Philadelphia
hmm we don't have an image let me see if
we go forward no okay
well the image is there pretend that you
see the president's house which was it
was a lithograph an image of a
lithograph from the president's house
which actually right now for those of
you who are familiar with Philadelphia
if you go to the Liberty Bell and a
Constitution Hall the houses is actually
right there and I'll tell you this is
sort of an aside when I was watching
kind of all the the pre-election
coverage and there was a speech given by
former President Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton it was smack in the
middle of this courtyard it at
Independence Hall and I'm watching the
kind of the visual with with the crowds
and what-have-you and off to the right
was where the actual president's house
stood and I thought wow here we are I'm
watching this moment and off to the
right hand side ona's still there like
she just won't let me go she follows me
everywhere
February 1796
brought a palpable unease to the
Executive Mansion in Philadelphia a
thick tension prompted own a judge and
her enslaved companions to tread lightly
around George and Martha Washington
enslaved men and women always moved
about their days with caution
not knowing what events could sour or
sweeten and owners mood for the slaves
who resided within the same walls as
their owner life could be akin to
walking through fields embedded with
landmines
the smallest of matters such as the
accidental breaking of a dish or in
conveniently timed bad weather could
alter the disposition of an owner
although the president did not earn the
reputation as being a violent or
physically extremely punishing slave
owner he
did on occasion lose his temper own a
judge maneuvered through her daily tasks
at the president's house with a smooth
watchfulness perhaps attending to Martha
Washington with extra care as she helped
her dress for the day for seven years
judge had served her mistress well up
north she became Martha Washington's
closest body slave all who knew the
Washington's on a personal level were
familiar with judge for she often
accompanied her mistress on social calls
since moving to New York and then
Philadelphia the first lady's life was
filled with socializing and public
events and so it's important to realize
that this relationship between mistress
and slave an enslaved person at least in
terms of ona judge it was a very kind of
intimate relationship not necessarily in
the best of ways but ona was around
Martha Washington constantly helping her
with the most intimate of
responsibilities dressing bathing
combing hair and she was around she
heard everything that went on in the
executive mansion judge understood her
mistress she knew just how much Martha
Washington loved her grandchildren she
had outlived every single one of her
children fathered by her first husband
Martha Washington had no choice but to
look toward towards her grandchildren
for hope and enjoyment and although she
was only 27 years old when she married
George Washington their marriage never
yielded offspring after the death of her
son John Martha and George Washington
welcomed two of his small children into
their home raising them up through
adulthood and I think that's a really
interesting thing to think about the
kind of intergenerational relationship
or community that was actually there
from the beginning with the first
president I hope we have a picture we do
judge must have witnessed the shock and
concern of her owners after they read
through the mail on February 6th the
president received a letter from Eliza
his 19 year old step grandchild
informing her grandparents of her
intention to marry
Eliza wrote of her engagement to Thomas
Law a British businessman who came to
America only recently before in 1794 and
became involved in land development in
and around the federal city law meant
Eliza who was 20 years as jr. and a
romance turned into an engagement
Eliza's father was deceased
and in some ways George Washington stood
in as one of the sort of appropriate
surrogates to approve or reject the
marriage proposal the news must have
sent the Executive Mansion into a
tailspin although this was very personal
family business everyone who lived
within the walls of the president's
house knew exactly what was happening
and it's interesting when we read some
of the letters John Adams writes about
this kind of interesting situation this
relationship that Eliza's Custis law is
entering into there were questions about
who this Thomas law was and he writes
writes home about the situation neither
George nor Martha Washington knew about
the seriousness of the relationship
between Eliza and law and there was much
to be concerned about with this Union
law arrived in America with two of his
three children both of whom were the
offspring from a relationship with an
Indian woman they were biracial his
biracial children and his age most
certainly raised the eyebrows of the
Washington's they were also concerned
that he might decide to go back to
England and could take Eliza with him
own a judge watched her owners feel
their way through the dramatic event
a February of 1796 Martha Washington's
concerns must have turned to optimism
because by the end of the month she
began to publicly announce the upcoming
matrimony she sort of moved through her
fear her concern her anger for not
knowing about this and began to sort of
think about this union in the most
positive way possible ona judge had no
idea that the acceptance of the marriage
by both George and Martha Washington
would begin the unraveling of her life
so Eliza Parke Custis married Thomas law
on March 21st 1796 and the marriage
signaled the beginning of major changes
for the Washington's and for their
slaves judge most certainly knew that
her time in Philadelphia was limited by
the March wedding of Eliza close family
knew that George Washington would not
run again for president this was no
secret in the executive mansion and
eventually all of their lives would
change once they returned to Mount
Vernon the idea of reconnecting with
loved ones in Virginia must have given
some of the slaves in the executive
mansion reason to celebrate but Judge
had lived in the north for seven years
and the thought of returning to Mount
Vernon did not settle well a return to
Mount Vernon was a reminder to judge and
her enslaved companions that they were
considered the property of another
person and after living in a free
northern city this was a difficult
concept to swallow for own a judge
however the uncertainty vanished as her
fate was revealed and I think it's
important to realize that ona judge
comes to Philadelphia as a teenager
she's seventeen sixteen seventeen years
old
and she spends these kind of formative
years
in Philadelphia watching free black
Philadelphia grow
she watched richard allen build mother
Bethel around the corner just about she
saw free black men and women selling
pepper pot soup and fruit on the streets
they were entrepreneurs and it wasn't
necessarily easy but she saw freedom she
could almost feel it taste it smell it
she would go to the circus go to the
theater these are things she would never
have been able to do in Virginia and
then with the marriage of Eliza she
realizes that her fate or at least her
fate was revealed this marriage and
change of life circumstances would cut
judges residency in Philadelphia short
unlike the other slaves of the executive
mansion ona would not return to
Philadelphia from her annual summer
sojourn to Mount Vernon judge would not
be around to witness the president's
final months in office Martha
Washington's deep concern for her
granddaughter trumped any relationship
that she may have forged with Judge
sensing that Eliza had entered into a
marriage for which she was unprepared
the first lady made a decision and of
course the term first lady isn't used at
this moment it's not used until later on
in the 19th century but I do use it as
part of this narrative that I've offered
the first lady made a decision that
would help her granddaughter navigate
through the transition of marriage she
would give own a judge to eliza Custis
although judge had earned the top spot
among Martha Washington's personal
slaves there was no way for judge to
amass enough personal or emotional
capital to convince her owner to change
her
find judges feet was now in the hands of
Eliza Custis law a woman who was
approximately the same age and was known
for having a difficult sometimes
volatile temper I always show this image
because I figured sort of gives us an
idea of Eliza she was a force to be
reckoned with sometimes I think maybe
she got a little bit of a bad rap but
her family wrote about her her temper
and this would have been something that
own a judge was familiar with a shift to
the household of the irritable and
volcanic Eliza Custis law would most
likely doom to a life of poor treatment
and uncertainty and she simply couldn't
let that happen we're going to read
another passage from the book to give
you an idea of what that moment was like
for her
judge knew what the future held should
she not heed the advice of her free
black associates she supposed if she
went back to Virginia she would never
have the chance to escape once she
learned that upon the decease of her
master and mistress she would become the
property of a granddaughter of theirs by
the name of Custis she knew that she had
to flee she imagined that her work for
the laws would begin immediately not
after the death of her owners prompting
a fierce clarity about her future and
her dislike for Eliza Custis law in her
interview at the end of her life she
said quote she was determined never to
be her slave her decision was made she
would risk everything to avoid the
clutches of the new mrs. law judge was
well informed and knew that her decision
to flee was far more than risky but
still she was willing to face dog
sniffing kidnappers and bounty hunters
for the rest of her life yes her fear
was consuming but so too was her anger
judge could no longer stomach her
enslavement and it was the change in her
ownership that pulled the trigger on
judges fury she had given everything to
the Washington's for 12 years she had
served her mistress faithfully and now
she was to be discarded like the scraps
of material that she cut from Martha
Washington's dresses any false illusions
she had clung to had evaporated and
judged knew that no matter how obedient
or loyal she may have appeared to her
owners she would never be considered
fully human her fidelity meant nothing
to the Washington's she was their
property to be sold mortgaged
or traded with whomever they wished the
beast that slept in every slave soul was
awakened confronting a future with Aliza
law coaxed the hunger for freedom out of
the recesses of judge's mind and now she
was willing to fight for what she
clearly believed to be her right her
decision to run was just the beginning
of her liberation the waiting was
difficult for nearly two weeks judge had
to calm her nerves and suppress her
anger as allies completed the planning
for her escape she could not raise
suspicions so Judge worked in tandem
with the rest of the household as they
made the necessary preparations for a
lengthy trip back to Mount Vernon judge
later stated quote whilst they were
packing to go to Virginia I was packing
to go I did nowhere for I knew that if I
went back to Virginia I never should get
my Liberty judge kept her plans a secret
making certain not to share information
with anyone who lived in the executive
mansion
she knew that fearful or jealous slaves
were often responsible for foiled
fugitive escapes she decided to rely on
the assistance of free blacks who
resided outside of the walls of the
president's home not only did own a
judge have to pack her things to leave
she also had to determine when she would
escape although the Executive Mansion
possessed more slaves and servants then
did most northern residences judge was
the first lady's preferred house slave
and had to be available at all times for
whatever reason there was only one duty
from which she was exempt meal
preparation the famed Hercules and a
kitchen staff prepared all the meals
served to the president and the first
family judge sometimes received a bit of
free time
during the afternoon meal and the
evening supper as other servants or
slaves were assigned to serve the
Washington's the president sometimes
entertained dinner guests extending the
festivities into the evening and
inviting guests to retire to the parlor
to enjoy a bit of wine an additional
conversation this would be the only
moment that judge could use to her
advantage
and when the moment arrived she gathered
her steely nerves and fled on Saturday
May 21st 1796 ona Judge slipped out of
the Executive Mansion
while the Washington's ate their supper
she disappeared into the free black
community of Philadelphia although we
have judge makes this decision to leave
I think one thing that I want people to
understand about the lives of fugitives
is to remember that the plan to escape
to leave was almost always strategic and
planned it wasn't typically a whim or
emotional and in the case of ona judge
we have this same thing in effect her
escape would be careful and calculated
she knew the moment that she walked out
of the president's mansion that her
status as a trusted house slave for the
most powerful American family would
immediately come to an end no longer
would judge be the favored slave of her
mistress instead she would be a fugitive
on May 23rd 1796 Frederick KITT the
households Stewart to George Washington
placed an ad in the Philadelphia Gazette
and actually for the week after her
disappearance there were at least two
newspapers claypoole's daily American
advertiser and which we have appear as
well as the Philadelphia Gazette not the
Pennsylvania Gazette this is the moment
that I tell my students you can't
believe everything you see on Wikipedia
because for the longest time the ad was
attributed to the Pennsylvania Gazette
that was incorrect it was the
Philadelphia Gazette and for a week
they ran advertisements to attempt to
recapture own a judge in in the
Philadelphia Gazette we have this ad
that describes own a judge announces to
the world that she had defied the
president from one of the ads absconded
from the household of the President of
the United States on Saturday afternoon
only judge and I contend that they use
she was called Oni and unwritten about
as Oni judge here at Mount Vernon in
Philadelphia and New York I believe it
was the diminutive of her name like
little Oni and I choose to call her ona
which is the name she went by at the end
of her life but in this newspaper Oni
judge a light mulatto girl much freckled
with very black eyes and bushy black
hair she's of middle stature slender and
delicately made about twenty years of
age and the language changes a little
bit in some of the advertisements this
one offers of course a ten dollar reward
which was about the cost of a barrel of
flour at that time another sort of
interesting thing to note is that this
advertisement offers the reward and is
very clear they say this ten dollars
will be paid to anyone white or black
this is written in the first ads that
appear subsequently that language was
taken out which I thought was
interesting but clearly this was a play
to the free black community who may have
seen
witnessed or do something about ona's
escape Frederic kits ad in the
Philadelphia Gazette alerted slave
catchers to judges probable escape route
the Delaware River in his advertisement
kit sent a strong warning to anyone who
worked on the docks of Philadelphia's
busy port stating quote but as she may
attempt to escape by water all matters
of vessels are cautioned against
admitting her into them kits assumptions
were correct for judge did escape the
city by boat a combination of
preparation assistance from the black
community steely nerves pushed the
trusted enslaved woman to begin her life
anew as a fugitive and it's at this
point in the in the book where I sort of
move into this transition from ona judge
as an enslaved woman in Virginia and
then New York and Philadelphia to
becoming a fugitive and her life changes
instantly the moment she walks out of
that door and it begins on her voyage to
New Hampshire I'll read just a bit
the crashing waves of the Atlantic Ocean
hurled saddles and candles from one side
of the storage hole to another the smell
of molasses and coffee was thick
nauseating passengers who were
unaccustomed to sailing with bowls on
his frequent trips between Philadelphia
New York and Portsmouth transportation
in the 18th century was never easy and
traveling by sea could be dangerous old
and poorly inspected ships slipped in
and out of cities with torn sails and
weathered caulking hoping to make it to
the next port without incident own a
judge but had never before sailed on
such a ship a single masted sloop that
could carry up to 75 people depending on
the size of the cargo these vessels were
designed to haul Freight from one
coastal town to the next
but ship captains like Boles earned
extra money by allowing passengers to
ride along any seafaring voyages that
Judge might have taken with the
Washington's would have been close to
enjoyable short river crossings and
relatively luxurious vessels were what
judge had come to know but she had
turned her back on all of that now on
board the Nancy ship was minimal space
was minimal and travelers lodged
themselves wherever there was room once
again the fugitive found herself
sleeping in tight quarters but this time
it was with strangers some who were
traveling home to visit with family and
friends and others who like judge were
leaving behind a difficult past for the
possibilities of a new future and
Portsmouth the unsettled sea likely
forced judges stomach to turn
somersaults sending her to look for
refuge from nausea
Dec the wind would cool her flushed and
sweaty forehead offering temporary
relief from seasickness
surely other passengers suffered the
same way hanging their bodies over the
sides of the sloop releasing the
contents of their stomachs into the
Atlantic every morning when the Sun
lifted lifted itself above the horizon
judge would have looked out across the
ocean thankful to have survived another
day away from her owners but still she
was terrified for five days judge
contained her fear she could not appear
too nervous as passengers were already
throwing quick and curious glances
toward the light-skinned black woman who
traveled alone she knew that the
Washington's were looking for her and
that by now her name and a bounty
probably appeared in many of the
Philadelphia newspapers she wondered how
much of a reward was attached to her
recapture a thought that sent her eyes
to scan the strangers on board surely
none of the Washington's agents had made
it to bowl ship before it left dock
Street but she wouldn't know this for
certain until the Nancy reached New
Hampshire the beautiful expense of
clothing that she wore to serve the
Washington's was packed away and instead
Judge would have dressed in and [ __ ] in
conspicuous clothing allowing her to
hide in plain sight she was a hunted
woman and would try to pass not for
white but as a free black northern woman
ona would have to fight to stay free the
Washington's would pursue her for years
up until really three months before the
president died so for years ona had to
try and figure out how to remain never
caught see if we have I want to show a
few of the kind of archival tidbits that
I was able to pull while I was working
on this project for for nine years the
researching and writing really took
almost a decade and during my process of
researching I kind of spanned this
moment where digitization was just
starting so newspapers thank goodness
are digitized now and it's sort of sped
things up as we went along but this is
one of the newspaper papers that I
looked through early on in my project
and this is another one of those it
would jump for joy moments when you
actually find what you're looking for
and the archives and of course this is a
an announcement a marriage announcement
in this town mr. John stains to miss
Oney judge her name was spelled
incorrectly or differently so took me a
while to to find this but what I find so
incredible about this or a couple things
one this is January of 1797 so she
hasn't been gone but what seven months
eight months or so and in that time
she's able to find a husband and not
only did she find a husband but she
didn't go by an alias when she reported
or got married and had to report to the
paper about this this marriage now this
is also another note for for graduate
students those scholars who are happy
about digitization just to see this
image is important right we see this is
a sort of act of her life her resistance
maybe but if you pull out the whole page
of the
paper and of course I don't have that
slide here but the on the the front page
of this newspaper was George
Washington's announcement to the fair
people of New Hampshire thanking them
for his for for being good citizens as
he prepared to depart and so what's
hilarious to me is we have George
Washington making this statement to the
great people of New Hampshire and in the
column next to it as a slave a just ran
away or Martha slave who just ran away
so looking at the entire document gives
you a better sense for the kind of
resistance we see coming from ona judge
whether she knew it whether she meant to
be that much of a sort of resisting
person we don't know ona judge would
make her way to freedom or relative
freedom she would live out her days in
and around Greenland New Hampshire and
she evaded Washington's slave catching
acquaintances for the entirety of her
life she managed to build a family for
herself she married she had children she
worked as a domestic to the end of her
days and although she endured the trials
of poverty and fugitive status until her
death
judge moved forward her life was a
difficult one but freedom was worth it
and I'll show you my last slide of the
evening is a little bit of one of the
first interviews that own a judge grants
I'm not going to tell you everything
about New Hampshire because you know you
got to buy the book and you know you got
to read the book so I don't want to give
everything away but remember the book is
called never console we know there's
going to be some tension in Jarama while
she's in New Hampshire but this article
that came from the granite Freeman which
was an abolitionist newspaper appeared
in May of of 1845 and it was at this
point owned a judge was in her early to
mid 70s and she granted an interview
and I wouldn't necessarily call on a
judge in abolitionist I'm not sure that
she saw herself as such she simply was
asked to tell her story and you know one
thing that I've noticed is I spend time
with my own mother and I've spent time
with my my grandparents the older you
get the more likely you are to say
what's exactly on your mind without much
filter and I think we have a bit of that
here with ona judges interviews she
explains why she ran away how she ran
away and why it was important but also
that she didn't regret it even though
her life was terribly difficult she
never regretted it she would spend
nearly 50 years as a fugitive and the
children that she had were also
fugitives because slavery followed the
apron strings of the mother so the
stakes were even higher once ona went to
New Hampshire and attempted to be to
remain never caught for 50 years she was
a fugitive in hiding but I'm certain
that she never wanted to be forgotten
with the publication of this book
everyone will now know her name thank
you
[Applause]
so I think we're going to do some QA and
we have two microphones stationed at
either side of the room
thank you for a fascinating talk were
you able to talk to descendants and get
any oral histories oh great good
question about descendants and oral
histories so how do I say this without
giving away part of the story the
descendants directly related to ona
judge don't exist but there are
descendants connected to her half
siblings and there's been some
correspondence between the library and
some of those folks who claim to be
descendants i actually purposefully
chose not to go to bark up that tree
although maybe that's the second project
i don't know but what we do have is a
record of some of her half siblings and
what happens to them once ona ona leaves
and one of the her siblings a sister
whose name was philadelphia is that i
know interesting so philadelphia is
actually forced to take onus place and
she goes to work for eliza Custis law
and as you know you got to buy the book
i don't want to tell you everything but
so there's a chapter in epilogue at the
end that explains I think really sort of
poignant Lee how we have two examples of
women in the early 19th century who were
trying to find freedom we have ona doing
it as a fugitive and as you'll see in
the book we have her sister attempting
to do it in other ways so it gets us
back to this issue of women attempting
to fight for their freedom but there is
a story there philadelphia marries a
Manning william Costin and becomes a
part of a really sort of relatively
well-known family in Washington DC and
I'll I'll just go ahead and tell you
that Philadelphia does find her freedom
her freedom I was wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit more on the free
black community in Philadelphia that the
ways that they might have been planning
for to a sister that's a great the
questions a great question about the the
Philadelphia free blacks in Philadelphia
and how they came to her aid I think one
of the important things about this story
this history is that it highlights the
importance of networks right and in
particular of communities free people of
color Philadelphia in the 1790s was the
epicenter of free black life it outpaced
New York gradual the gradual end of
slavery began in 1780 in Pennsylvania
with the gradual abolition all that
stated stated you could only be held as
a slave for up to 28 years and we saw
some elongation of that in some
instances but really we're own a judge
lived who's very close to many free
blacks and so we have thousands of of
free blacks living in and around
Philadelphia one thing that's important
to note is that ona judge never names
names and she can't write she can't do
that for fear of reprisals that those
who helped her they broke the federal
law they could be imprisoned or fined
and so she just simply referred to them
as free people of color or the colored
people of Philadelphia a couple of
historians including myself believe that
Richard Allen known for a creation of
Mother Bethel AME in Philadelphia was
likely involved in some way or another
in her escape he was known for assisting
fugitives and interestingly enough in
the account books held at the
Philadelphia executive mansion
a week before ona runs off it's noted
that she was given money to buy new
shoes smart right you're gonna run away
you need new shoes but one thing to
remember is that Richard Allen he was a
chimney sweep he served the household of
the president he would clean out the
chimneys there perhaps they interacted
were not certain and he also had a shoe
shop in his home he's his he was a sort
of jack-of-all-trades and so some of us
including rich Neumann who wrote the
biography on Richard Allen believed
there was at the very least some kind of
connection between her and Richard Allen
but we also see him in outside of
Philadelphia outside of seeing this
growing free black population who
clearly helped her she says it the only
person she names is John Bowles who was
a ship master and I was able to because
she named his name he was she made it
very clear in her article in her
interview that she was only naming his
name because she knew he was deceased so
that he wouldn't get in trouble but it
was very clear that following the the
ship reports that pulled into the port
of Philadelphia his ship was in
Philadelphia at exactly the time that
owned a judge ran away and made it back
to Portsmouth at the beginning of June
so and that's how I sort of figured out
that it was the ship was called the
Nancy by looking at ship advertisements
so clearly the free black community was
involved with her and with her fugitive
of her becoming a fugitive the same
holds true in New Hampshire and she's
very clear that she gets help and
assistance from the free black
population in New Hampshire
now the beany so when she arrives in
Portsmouth they're more black people in
Mount Vernon than there were in
Portsmouth still maybe I don't know
important Portsmouth's a lovely city
I've spent a lot of time there
absolutely gorgeous but it you know I
first thought when I found realized she
would do Portsmouth I was like
Portsmouth why Portsmouth and then I
realize
she couldn't go to New York she was
unknown entity she was a face that was
recognizable perhaps the same was true
for Boston she says she didn't really
know in her interviews where she was
going so it was likely that those free
black people that helped her they didn't
tell her for fear of you know problems
that perhaps she would tell the plan
perhaps she would be found out so she
actually doesn't know where she's going
until she disembarks
and once she gets to New Hampshire she
finds a free black community there who
harbors her who gives her housing and
food and helps her find work and really
keeps her safe every time one of
Washington's agents or family members
came after her they always sheltered her
harbored her hit her and so I think the
other part of what this book does is
show the importance of a free black
community in the 19th a tend of the 18th
and early 19th century a few years ago I
read a wonderful children's book to my
daughter about Oney judge were you part
of that project no I know the the author
if it was Diane Turner she's written a
children's book no I wasn't a part of
that but I know her work and I'm glad
that those there I think there are two
children's books about about on a judge
and now there's some interest about a
kind of young adult version so I'm
working on that stay tuned
in the slide you have up there right now
it says simple you did have up there it
says something to the effect that she
didn't remember what year it was and I'm
kind of surprised at that you would
think it would be burned in her memory
yeah I think it it would be burned in
one's memory but here I'll let you sneak
in and I'll come off and just talk
louder I think we also have to think
about the importance of history and
memory and what especially an interview
at the end of one's life although that
was she gave us pretty good details she
does say look I can't remember the year
and I don't even think that's too
difficult oh you're coming back thank
you thanks I don't think that's too
difficult you know to sort of wrap our
minds around because I know personally I
can't remember what happened last week
let alone you know what year things
happened in and I think she wanted to
provide an interview that was as
credible as possible but she didn't lie
and in some ways I kind of appreciate
that she doesn't that she says I can't
remember I don't know and I think about
that you know 50 years as a fugitive at
a time when and as a fugitive and
remember she could not read or write and
she doesn't become literate until the
end of her life so I think it's sort of
possible very possible that she doesn't
remember and so I appreciate the honesty
did the pursuit of ona judge continued
after the Washington's passed away so
she says no she's never states that
anyone else from Martha's side of the
family came after her when we think
about we know that Martha Washington and
her will hurt the estate rather was
transferred to her grandchildren so
technically owned a judge would have
belonged to one of them now I've looked
through the inventory of the enslaved
for all those grandchildren she's not
noted anywhere on on those lists and in
some ways I kind of think well they just
sort of gave up but it's a sort of
fascinating story because her
grandchildren really sort of moved in
separate ways about slavery
we know George Washington Park Custis
becomes involved in American
Colonization Society
Eliza Custis law some of her slaves are
emancipated so there's it's almost like
a different story that we move into in
the 19th century it sort of captures
this transition between the end of the
18th and the early 19th century I found
no record of it and ona did not mention
the possibility of being an attempted
capture by any of the grandchildren so
you know I think that's an important
point but she was pursued for at least
three years right we know that from the
moment that she runs away until the
death of George Washington she's pursued
and so one of the things I think we have
to remembers even though there wasn't a
sort of physical attempt to capture her
she knew that she was still their
property and as long as slavery existed
in the United States
she was never not she was always at risk
and so I do think it's important to note
that the grandchildren did not appear to
go after her maybe some document will
fall out
a desk somewhere and tell me a different
story and if that happens I'm I'm
excited not worried but she clearly
always knew that she was a fugitive and
that was a fear that rang true to her
and her children
over here Erika does really good work
you doing here I've got a question for
you so does own it give me any insight
into George Washington's planning of the
capital city with Ellicott and Banneker
does she give anything into the inside
dealing with its layout based on Kemet
societies and the rest you have any
information that would talk I wish she'd
had you know I wish but she didn't you
know she and we have really just two
interviews from her and the information
that she gives about Washington George
Washington and Martha Washington really
revolved around religion because it was
clear that she became very ona became
very religious at the end of her or
during her life as a fugitive went to
church it's there where she learned she
became literate we're not certain if she
could write or not but at least could
read so she talked more about religion
she talked about the desire to not go to
the granddaughters she talked about the
fact that she never regretted this
decision but she didn't give us the kind
of intricacies of what was going on and
I find that kind of fascinating because
think about it she lived with them for
so long like she knew everything right
she was there she witnessed the
difficult moments but she never went
there she didn't give up that kind of
personal information she takes a few
jabs at the Washington's but you know
give her a break she was a slave through
the fugitive she has a right to you know
put in some jabs there's a washing shoe
she questioned whether or not George
Washington was really religious she said
I never really saw him pray he went to
church but he didn't pray and so I think
that's a different
kind of understanding about religion
from her viewpoint but she doesn't give
us those intricacies but what's so inch
I do talk a little bit about Banneker in
the book but just as a way to give
context for what the early era of the
United States looked like and he's part
of them I find it interesting that you
started your research on about the
announcement that you really weren't
looking for at the time and then you you
you hit the jackpot by finding finding
the interview and I was wondering was
that part of your you know a long
process when you did that or what led
you to find the report of the interview
yeah that's a jackpot I do as a
historian I think I can say that I don't
know if I would call a jackpot I just
feel like this kind of recovery work is
so important and to have this story out
for a large audience is the same I
didn't necessarily know so I'll be
honest here and I'm doing it on c-span
but I'll be honest here and I did not
know if I would actually be able to find
enough to write a book about onna like
there were children's books there was
maybe there were a chapter here there
and a couple of sort of important
biographies on Washington but no sort of
book about her and I when I first
started the research I was like what why
am i why is there nothing on her that's
kind of crazy and then I realized how
long it took to do this research and I
realized why there was nothing no kind
of monograph dedicated to her because
the materials are slim and that's
another reason why I said before that I
couldn't have done this had I not
written a fragile freedom which taught
me sort of everything about early
Philadelphia and New York and
sort of allowed me to ground this book
in those communities of free people in
the kind of atmosphere of the streets
and also what slavery looked like in
Philadelphia and in New York and then of
course Portsmouth
so at first I didn't know if I would be
able to to do a write a whole book and
then as time kind of kept moving I
realized I can and she deserves it
what can you tell us about owners
husband and I think I noticed in the
wedding announcement that the last name
her last name was spelt with a G at the
beginning rather than a J and I was
wondering whether that was an attempt to
maintain some anonymity and secrecy yeah
so the question was about her husband
Jack Staines who also went by John
stains sometimes what I was able to find
out about him was he was a free black
man he was a sailor a seaman and that
was a very sort of typical employment
opportunity for black men because
opportunities were few and far between
black men typically had to look to the
seas to earn a living and you know it
was some time it was sporadic money but
you could you would get all your money
at once and that was kind of the jackpot
moment where you brought home your your
earnings and was also very dangerous
work the minute you left Portsmouth or
Philadelphia or what-have-you and sailed
to other locations your freedom was
always in jeopardy so to think about you
know ona knew she was marrying a sailor
and she knew that he would be away for
long periods of time so that kind of
protection that many looked for at least
through marriage in terms of having a
male a husband or spouse who could help
especially a free person it wasn't
always at play for ona she spent a lot
of time alone at first when I was
working on the book there were some
there were notes that he kind of
disappeared from her family like he just
kind of fell off the face of the earth
and so it took me a long time trying to
track down what happened and so I didn't
bring an image of this but I had another
one of those moments when I found a
death notice for him in the New
Hampshire Gazette and it said Jack
stains a man of color died this day
because at first I wondered well did he
die at sea did he leave on a judge what
you know was there
marital tension that made him run off
and we know that she's alone
or 1804 why is that but that kind of
advert that little death announcement
the fact that they offered one for him
as a black man was also significant so I
was able to to find that piece that
together about him I don't know anything
about his beginnings I just know that he
was a free black man he married ona they
had children and that their marriage was
relatively short before he died and once
again kind of leaving ona to fend for
herself in many ways you know I wish
this could be a story where you know it
was triumph its triumphant in that she
stays away right she she's never caught
but life was really very difficult and
it was the same way for ona as it was
for many of the other free and enslaved
and fugitives who were living in New
Hampshire we're passing the mic down
thank you for all this wonderful
information my question is as the
fugitive was there any physical
description of her yeah yeah so there
were actually it will aside from the
advertisement when we get a description
of her as a young woman so she's about
22 when she runs off and and it it kind
of confirms what we think are what I
know about her background described her
as lighter complected with bushy hair
later on there were several accounts by
local folks in Portsmouth who wrote
their kind of recollections of life and
she made it into you know she was that
eventually she becomes known in
Portsmouth as oh yeah the slave who ran
away from Washington so people would
come to the cottage where she lived and
she was you know she was pretty
poverty-stricken and sometimes they'd
give her a dollar and and she would tell
them about her stories and so I've seen
her described as from very very light
complected almost white - copper colored
and so but so there are descriptions
about her not about her children but
about her so we do have an idea of
course unfortunately no image but once
again as a fugitive you wouldn't want
people to necessarily know what you look
like or at least to keep talking about
it did we get one more
thank you we just this past weekend
we're fortunate enough to go to the
Black History Museum and well we spent
the afternoon we only made it through a
few floors you need sneakers for that
breath yes if we go back well there'll
be any mention of ona Judd or yes so I I
went and gave a talk at the National
Museum of African history and culture
last week when the book came out I wish
there was you know a lot on her but no
there isn't
except for that I went gave a talk and
so you know the exhibit can change and
maybe that will happen but they
definitely one thing that's great is
that they're carrying the book in the
bookstore so you know they don't it
might not be in the exhibit but you can
at least buy the book in the bookstore
and I think that also has to do with a
lack of the material culture connected
to to ona because as I said before she
was a fugitive she left very little
behind in terms of a trace whereas if
you go to that magnificent Museum
you know there's Harriet Tubman shawl
silk shawl there's NAT Turner's Bible
there's you know so we have these
remnants from other very sort of famous
enslaved people we don't really have
anything in the way of material culture
that can be produced however I will say
you know this exhibit here made it
happen they still you know without the
material culture piece there's
definitely an engagement with owner
judge and she's represented so I
hopefully that will make it into that
grand building in DC well Erica thank
you so much let's get a round of
applause
that was that was really fantastic don't
run off yet you're not allowed to go yet
come on we're gonna we're gonna require
her to stay and sign everybody's books
and you're gonna buy multiple copies you
know I do appreciate what you said about
the exhibit here because when you know
when we had the slavery conference it
had just been open a weekly and I was
very curious to see you know how the
scholars would respond to it and do you
want to say anything else I know we have
some of the people who are involved in
these in the years I know you'd like it
yeah the exhibit I was one of those
folks who showed up in October at the
conference and I it's it's a exhibit
first visually a lot packed in and I
think it sort of signals a moment for
Mount Vernon that's really important
like slavery is a difficult topic and to
throw yourself into it and connect the
first president with the contradictions
the Apocrypha the chain and also sort of
looking at him as a man and his ideas
changing about slavery over time you
know I'm super appreciative that that
definitely makes it into the exhibit so
I've actually only heard sort of
positive positive comments about the
exhibit if you haven't seen it you
definitely should and Nonna's their own
it's there well thank you so much let's
give another big round of applause you
need a chair Thank You c-span
good night everybody you can buy books
right out the door there and Steve it
you just join Steven right over there
all right